I know why we're here a rescue op save
the dinosaurs from Island that's about
to explode what could go wrong I cannot
wait for to 2021 now because you guys
have set up like the thing that I want
it to be 2020 what is the thing you want
to see happen in part three it can be
random if you had any requests I mean
honestly the truth for me is that like
having in this movie dr. Ian Malcolm
Jeff Goldblum is like there's nothing
better than that
yeah honestly as cool as the dinosaurs
are that was pretty exciting so for me
what I would love to see in the third
movie is other cast members other return
cast members yeah I want to see somebody
who gets maimed at the beginning of the
movie and survives through the movie
with this horrible injury and we keep
coming back yeah maybe it's me my leg
I'm like you know yeah yeah no no that's
what happened yeah no but that's what
happened with Jeff in the first that's
why he's like in repose because he hurts
his leg right in Jurassic Park I think
it's these creatures were here before us
if we're not careful
they're gonna be here after I'm asking
everybody today their favorite Jeff
Goldblum stories but I want to know do
you see yourself in the next one I know
there's people to have to talk and
agents and whatever but would you do you
think your story there's more of your
story that needs to be told well who
knows they know better minds than I know
it's based on what they did with this
movie I think that's a neat trick that
they pulled off here it's really
satisfied people's you know and continue
their amazement and thrills and chills
and thought provocation and I'm a little
part of that I don't know if they think
I can contribute like what's happening I
don't know well good question you know
who's Colin Trevorrow who wrote this in
the wrote directed last one he's gonna
write direct the next one I tried to get
something out of him anything
he's supposedly working what's you in it
he said that yeah hey good news more
good news nothing else happens today
[Music]
welcome to Jurassic world do you once
that with Jeff Goldblum had you did you
meet him on set no we did not and he has
a coconut drink it's the cool ism yeah
you got to be at that party I wish I was
I loved I met him he gave me a hug and
then he said my my lip mole was a
chocolate pillow mint Wow I know right
I'm gonna keep that forever
I know did he go like this cousin I
probably I don't remember I was so
entranced life cannot be contained life
[Music]
fines away I'm gonna jump right in
because I'm very impatient you know I
have to wait till 21 for this next one
after you just without spoiling anything
set up the most crazy amazing world that
I can't wait to see I am feel the same
way
yeah I that is a you know the world that
we have been building to is a world I
wanted to see since I was a little kid
really but but this movie is this is the
Keystone this movie is is so important
and it's where everything changes so
getting this right and making sure we
had the right filmmaker to get it right
in J Bayona was I think that decision
making really decided whether that any
of this was going to work and I think
baiana did an incredible job something's
coming you're known for creating
suspense and there's so much suspense
built in this mansion do you have a
personal story of something crazy that's
happened to you in a house you drawn
anything house not in a house but I
remember for example when I was a kid I
saw by accident Dracula and I was by
accident of course because I was my
probably like five six years old and I I
was so terrified about horror films and
I remember that by accident I saw
Chocula and there is a scene in Jurassic
world falling Kingdom that is a reflect
on that it's a moment where you can see
the interrupter is sneaking through the
window of may see the little girl in the
story and that was inspired by that
movie well I think that will be the
scene and the in the picture people will
take away from this film in their head I
you know when you work in Jurassic movie
you really try to get memorable moments
with iconic shots that will stay in them
in the audience in their minds and I
really liked that moment I think it's
one of them my favorite moments in the
film
you
you